1 68
41 and 64. and so you're like that's
quite a nice magic square except it
doesn't work if you add them up you get
different numbers in different
directions
if i go through now and square all of
these numbers
that becomes a magic square
or rather it becomes a semi-magic square
so this is so close to being a magic
square of square numbers so all the rows
add to the same number all the columns
add to the same number
no one has ever found
a magic square that works properly both
diagonals
and all the numbers are square numbers
it's an open question in mathematics and
so people actually compete there there
are sorts of squares we haven't found so
uh people trying to find a four by four
magic square with cube numbers or you
know a 7x7 magic square
with uh square numbers right and so
there are prizes for all the ones we
haven't come across just last year
someone found the first 7x7 magic square
with all cube numbers and they won a
prize they won 500 euros it's all right
i mean you know and fame and
mathematical
you know what's their name
okay yeah yeah
let me take my notes uh yeah they're
really famous okay now in mathematics
the word fame means something slightly
different to what it means to everyone
else
means fame means every century someone
will look your name up in an obscure
book so uh so i thought you know what
i'm gonna try and find one so i wanted
to try and find the proper magic square
with all square numbers because there's
a thousand euros for that one that's the
one i'm after three by three or three by
three i'm a purist uh do you wanna see
what i found right here's what i found
147 41 37 1 23 41 29 all right so
there's my fella uh there are a few
problems with this one for a start it
does work so if i go through if i square
all of these
and then i check the adding up the total
for this square is 3051
and it works for all the columns it
works for all the rows it only works for
one of the diagonals so this diagonal
here works this diagonal here doesn't
work and so it's a semi-magic square
also as you may have spotted some
numbers are in there more than once so
you see there's two 41s there's 229s
there's two ones some people would say
that makes it less of a magic square i
would say that you would say that you're
with the vast majority of humans in
there you could just put all the same
number in there no yeah okay no it's a
very good point so a magic square all
the same number over and over would
still technically be a very
disappointing magic square
and so i mean to be honest
it's a bit like you know you know you
always think your children or your pets
are the greatest in the world and you
put lots of videos of them up online for
me i mean everyone else is like it's not
a very nice square is it don't when
should we tell matt he seems so excited
about it you know what i am excited
about it this is my square and so i will
admit i'm looking at it through
rose tinted square glasses but i like it
it's it's it it's a semi-magic
square with repeated entries and it's
got square numbers in it and
my fine has it got a name
that hasn't got a name i don't want to
call it the parker square because it
doesn't work properly it would be like
oh that's a classic parker square or
something would do something that's
almost right but not quite like that's a
real parker square kind of move so i'm
not calling it the parker square you
know what this video is i'm caught up
for crying out loud
the first time you name something after
me
is something that's not quite right you
know what maybe i'll become the mascot
for giving things a go people suspect
one may exist or may not i don't know
they can't rule it out but it's
generally agreed
it's not achievable with our current
computing power or our current number
theory to be able to find one of these
but i gave it a go right and of course i
didn't find it i found this
this adequate
and you know it's like it's like
i'll tell you what matt i don't think
this is our best number five video but
it was a parker square of a number
stop trying to make parker square a
thing
or this diagonal or that diagonal they
add up all this little square in here
they all add up to the same number which
is one seven
six magic hexagon if it exists has to be
of size three so it's three layers
you've got the one in the center you've
got your second layer and your third
layer